bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
la justice ouvre une enquête sur une
dizaine de décès survenus à l'hôpital
edouard herriot de lyon il s'agit de
savoir si ces décès sont liés à la
coupure de courant intervenue la semaine
dernière hausse du chômage au mois
d'août le monde le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi augmenté de 33 mille personnes
ce sont les saisonniers intérimaires
principalement première visite en france
de monsieur gerhard schröder celui qui
sera bientôt officiellement le nouveau
chancelier de la république fédérale
d'allemagne nous accorder un entretien
et puis à la veille de l'ouverture du 5e
mondial d'automobiles ne soient en
direct de ce salon avec vous benoît oui
tout à fait vous avez dit c'est le sait
le centenaire du salon de l'automobile
c'est ce qui fait en c'est ce qui on en
fait un événement assez extraordinaire
tout simplement parce qu'il a son temps
comme ces voiturettes peugeot et renault
qui sont derrière moi et puis aussi
parce qu'il y à une quarantaine de
nouveautés exposées cette année ça ne
s'était jamais vu et vous le verrez en
découvrant ces voitures et bien que
l'heure est plutôt à la gaîté on est
loin des formes quelquefois un peu
rigide et triste d électriser puis autre
événement un peu exceptionnelle chez
nous ce soir est bien pour la première
fois les deux grands patrons des deux
grands groupes français peugeot et
renault
monsieur fall c'est monsieur choisir ont
accepté de dialoguer en direct à la
télévision
ça aussi c'est un événement et sadio sur
france 2 ça sera tout à l'heure je vous
trouverez ici en direct du salon de
l'automobile à lyon la panne
d'électricité survenue à l'hôpital
edouard herriot à la fin de la semaine
dernière une panne de courant de deux
heures pourrait être à l'origine du
décès d'une dizaine de personnes il
convient d'user du conditionnel mais la
justice a décidé d'élargir son enquête
l'équipe médicale et administrative de
l'hôpital toujours affirmé cependant que
ces décès n'avaient aucun rapport avec
la panne électrique pour tenter de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
l'enchaînement des faits voyez le
reportage de benoît gadret thierry
simonet samedi 26 septembre 0 1 heure 30
le deuxième hôpital de france est
plongée dans le noir près de 2h30 sans
électricité du jamais vu
la faute à une pièce de quelques
centimètres carrés situé dans cette
armoire
une pièce de contact qui sous l'effet
d'une panne de secteur s'est détériorée
le système s'est mis en sécurité et
empêche le basculement sur les deux
alimentation de secours
selon le syndicat fo de l'hôpital il
s'écoulera une heure et quinze minutes
avant que la société privée chargée de
la maintenance commence à intervenir sur
le système électrique vous avez des tas
de services qui sont les services pilote
à tout point de vue et on se retrouve
tout d'un cou bloqué neutralisée par une
simple coupure d'électricité c'est ya de
la super puis à l'indignation c'est pas
possible
720 malades sont hospitalisés cette nuit
là les plus graves en service de
réanimation là où l'électricité alimente
les appareils de dialyse et surtout de
ventilation les médecins assurent avoir
fait face donc voilà ce qui se passe
encore coupures d'électricité par
exemple on sait la même chose donc
immédiatement toute personne présente
médecins ou infirmières va se saisir
d'un appareil de ventilation manuel qui
dit 'tiens bayésiens louvre l'oxygène en
grande quantité et il remplace le
respirateur par cet appareil manuel mais
dans l'incertitude les médecins décident
de transférer 26 malades vers d'autres
hôpitaux 2 décéderont dans les heures
qui suivent dont robert séguin ce
sexagénaire souffrait d'un cancer il
venait d'être opéré sa famille à qui un
médecin avait laissé quelques espoirs
envisage aujourd'hui de porter plainte
les infirmières et infirmiers sont pas
en cause ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
manuellement mais je pense pas que des
mains les mains puisse remplacer les
machines il est dialysé il avait une
toute petite chance de vivre encore donc
on nous l'a dit bon elle était peut-être
petit peut-être les suites de
l'opération se serait mal passé
peut-être qu'on peut en rajouter tant
qu'on peut mais il ya quand même une
toute petite chance qu'il s'en soit
sortie sud de ces décès des conséquences
de la panne la direction de l'hôpital ne
parlera que tardivement sous la pression
des médias
les médecins affirment que la coupure
n'a eu aucune incidence sur le décès de
patients qui était en fin de vie
nous l'utilisons par la langue de bois
mais de votre côté il ne faut pas avoir
de suspicion je peux vous garantir qu'il
n'y a aucun aucune affection ou qu'un
décès suspects ici sûrs
des autopsies seront pratiquées demain
par deux médecins experts dont un suisse
sur huit des dix patients décédés qui
font l'objet d'une enquête ordonnée par
la justice
par ailleurs des médecins chefs de
service ont été ou seront entendus par
la police dans les prochaines heures en
conseil des ministres ce matin le
président chirac a demandé que les
causes et les responsabilités de ces
décès soit établi et que l'on s'assure
que de tels accidents ne puisse pas se
reproduire quant au maire de lyon
monsieur raymond barre il appelle à la
prudence pour éviter toute
interprétation prématurés ou abusives
vous voulez savoir comment dans un
hôpital ou un établissement public
différent tel un aéroport on prévoit une
éventuelle coupure de courant
quelles sont les procédures de sécurité
mises en place voici l'exemple labiche à
l'hôpital bichat à paris et à l'aéroport
de roissy reportage benoît thevenet
andré sera la vie d'un malade suspendu
au fonctionnement de la machine dans un
service de réanimation électricité est
vital
le courant électrique est fournie par
edf il y à la source principale et en
cas de coupure une source auxiliaires
prend le relais pour alimenter l'hôpital
c'est le 2 les 200 défaillante nous
avons un basculement automatique sur que
cette source d'énergie
fournis à partir pour que les prochaines
qui eux mêmes sont alimentés à partir de
cuivre de fioul sur toujours en
préchauffage qui sont prêtes à démarrer
dans le 30 secondes qui suivent
détection de métaux lourds sur le réseau
les 30 secondes seront invisibles sur
les appareils de l'hôpital grâce à 17
tonnes de batteries mais ces batteries
ont une autre fonction elles sont
capables de fournir de l'énergie au bloc
opératoire et à la réanimation pendant
30 minutes
une sécurité en cas de défaillance des
groupes électrogènes
même si les trois appareils sont mises
en marche deux fois par mois pour
vérifier leur état
une panne est toujours possible enfin
cas rarissime il peut arriver qu aucune
sécurité mais fonctionné alors c'est le
personnel hospitalier
comme à lyon il ya quelques jours qui
maintient manuellement la respiration
artificielle
dernière journée devant les jurés les
magistrats de la cour d'assises de paris
au procès de florence rey hier l'avocat
général avait réclamé 30 ans de
réclusion contre la jeune femme accusée
du meurtre de quatre personnes cet après
midi les avocats de la défense plaidait
maître henri leclerc le défenseur de
florence rey s'en est pris dominique
verdeilhan l'avocat général
oui parce que accusé florence rey
d'avoir tué le chauffeur de taxi pour
maître leclerc c'est un coup bas parce
que cela n'apparaît pas dans le dossier
d'instruction
et puis parce que ça n'a pas été
développée durant le procès la deuxième
salle de maître leclerc ce sont les
trente ans requis proprement dit c'est
injuste dit il
florence rey ne doit pas payer à la
place d'audry maupin
florence rey se bat pour ne pas être une
héroïne un exemple un modèle alors n'en
fait pas un martyr par une peine lourde
troisième axe de défense florence rey
criminels malgré elle
je vous invite à écouter maître henri
leclerc quelques minutes après sa
plaidoirie
les jeunes adolescentes qu'elles ont été
entraînés dans un enchaînement qu'elle
n'a pas maîtrisé en transférant panique
de peur
la peine qu'on a demandé grand trail est
une peine terrible et qu' il est faux de
croire les gens de combat les peines
quand l'orage ils les font
alerte les jurés sur le fait que les
libérations conditionnelles sont pour
ainsi dire inexistante dans les dossiers
de meurtres de policiers il rappelle que
ce type de crime est exclue des grâces
du 14 juillet dernier point un peu
inattendu pour maître henri leclerc
florence rey s'est très mal défendu
durant son procès n'a pas trouvé les
mots nécessaires il lui a même dit vous
avez été nul
la parole a été donnée en dernier à
florence rey comme le prévoit la loi
elle a préféré ne rien dire merci
dominique condamnation à cinq ans de
prison dont un avec sursis pour deux
hommes reconnus coupables d'atteintes
sexuelles sur des mineurs de moins de 15
ans de cadrage nerfs adepte du tourisme
sexuel qui abusaient de jeunes enfants
lors de voyages au maroc au sri lanka
c'est le tribunal de bobigny qui a
prononcé cette peine et c'est une
première en matière judiciaire il faut
savoir que depuis la loi du 4 février 95
ces pratiques sont passibles de dix ans
de prison
en corse à furiani près de bastia une
intervention policière avec les hommes
du raid a été effectuée tôt ce matin au
domicile du secrétaire national du
mouvement à concoules ta indépendantiste
monsieur charles pierre au cours de la
preuve perquisitions des armes et des
explosifs ont été saisis de nombreux
militants nationalistes sont venus sur
place reportage agnès vahramian josé
boulesteix la sympathie et les
applaudissements des militants de la
concorde tu leur colère aussi manifestée
par un jet de pierres sur la voiture des
policiers qui emmène shaqiri son fils et
l'un de leurs proches au commissariat
très tôt ce matin dès la nouvelle connue
les militants se sont rassemblés devant
la maison de leur leader puis les
gendarmes mobiles sont arrivés
il a donc fallu discuter nous on reste
là
la meilleure a pas d'incidents quelques
heures auparavant
charles pieri interpellé à 6h du matin
devait répondre aux questions des
policiers
son domicile a été perquisitionné sans
aucun ménagement 60 bâton de 100 grammes
et 200 g de dynamite 15 pistolet
automatique de fusils ak 47
voilà ce qu'ont trouvé les policiers qui
ont aussi saisi des documents liés à la
con culte mais en petite quantité
c'est dans le cadre d'un meurtre celui
de ce jeune militant d'un camp
nationaliste opposé à la con paul
christophe garelli que cette opération a
eu lieu selon un témoin des militants de
l'organisation proche de charles pieri
était présent sur les lieux du drame
il y a deux jours nous rencontrions
justement charles pieri pour savoir s'il
ne se sentait pas inquiété dans cette
affaire est un profil public qui n'a
aucune responsabilité bien sûr dans
aucun drame et la question de ces
bizarres pour tous posé donc nous
occuper de ce drame d'ailleurs dans
plein d'autres mais c'est maintenant sur
les armes et devant les policiers de
l'antiterrorisme que charles pieri devra
s'expliquer son arrestation tombe mal
pour la con colts ces dernières semaines
douze militants dont son ancien leader
en prisonnier françois santoni ont
démissionné mais cet après midi à la con
coulton parlait de lutte pour
l'indépendance
individuellement nous faire du mal
effectivement c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ça continuera probablement
mais on ne peut pas arrêter cette lutte
mais ce soir après des démissions en
cascade et l'arrestation de son nouveau
leader la con colt est on ne peut plus
affaiblie
à noter que l'avocate maître matelly
chez qui on avait perquisitionné ce
matin a été interpellé puis relâché en
fin d'après midi
le fabricant mondial de jeans levi
strauss et annonce une restructuration
c'est à dire deux mille cinq cents
licenciements dans ses usines
américaines et européennes pour l'europe
le fabricant de jeans veut fermer quatre
usines trois en belgique et une en
france les usines françaises situées à
la basse et près de lille elle compte
530 salariés et comme leurs collègues
belges les ouvriers lillois ont été
stupéfaits par cette annonce reportage
marianne masse dominique maes
le travail a repris ce matin à la bassée
mais le coeur n'y était pas pas plus que
l'espoir
on a échappé une fois pas deux il faut
dire que la marge de manoeuvre semble
bien étroite
la direction met en avant la concurrence
de plus en plus rude la baisse des
ventes et les coûts de production trop
lourd pour rester dans la course
mondiale lévis avait besoin de faire des
coupes sombres
nous avons regardé les cours du forum
d'user nous avons actuellement 12 usines
en europe et les usa l'union belge et
qui fait en france saveurs le plus cher
si vous pensez que pour la main d'oeuvre
en production pour faire un jean à 28
fraudeurs c'est cher je ne comprends
rien du tout bien sûr va pas travailler
comme dans les pays de l'est comme en
pologne à 9 francs pourtant la crise
n'est pas récente et les salariés
avaient déjà dû subir des périodes de
chômage technique
coïncidence ou pas en 96 l'entreprise
avait reçu des subsides du plan borotra
des de textile l'année même où elle
ouvre à tunis et en tueur si son choc de
plus en plus et en turquie d'un
produisent de mouk de plus en plus
nous on va commander des lévis on va
commander à la fin on a des bons de
commande qu'on peut avoir tous les mois
on va voir un jimmy écrit made in
turquie lévis et lmd dernier gros
employeur du secteur alors pour le maire
le coup est rude
il pense forcément délocalisations on
vient d'être un petit peu surpris par
benetton qui lui dit carrément je m'en
vais en hongrie pour des raisons de
coûts salariaux et donc on y pense
automatiquement ça on peut pas
s'empêcher d'y penser en france et en
belgique 1480 sont aujourd'hui en sursis
les belges eux ont choisi de faire grève
au moins jusqu'à vendredi
tous y ont manifesté lundi à bruxelles
lors d'un comité européen du groupe
la ministre de l'emploi martine aubry
affirmait que la décision définitive
n'était pas encore prise
mauvais chiffres du chômage pour le mois
d'août le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
augmenté de 33 milles
cet accroissement est plus marquée pour
les hommes notamment les adultes âgés de
45 à 50 ans ces chiffres sont sans doute
liée à l'arrêt du travail des
saisonniers
cette recrudescence était prévisible et
le ministère de l'emploi rappelle que le
taux de chômage en france restent
inchangés il y à 2 millions neuf cent
quatre vingt dix sept mille 600 chômeurs
en france actuellement
parmi les mesures prises par le
gouvernement pour combattre le chômage
il y a les emplois jeunes beaucoup ont
été créés dans l'éducation nationale on
peut se risquer à faire un premier bilan
provisoire de l'efficacité de ces
emplois ça marche
même s'il ya quelques défections
reportage venoix gadret thierry simonet
en allemand metex idée parce qu'elle
allemands dans ce collège ils sont six
aides éducateurs depuis un an
un seul a démissionné les débuts ont été
difficiles
la mission mal définis mais avec le
temps ces jeunes diplômés ont su trouver
leur place essentiellement dans le
soutien scolaire 1 kg
combien de grammes c'est le travail
qu'on fait avec eux qui est différent et
qui qui ne trouve pas avec leurs
professeurs qui n'ont pas souvent le
temps non plus parce que 25 élèves
imaginez 25 élèves qui viennent chacun
leur tour à la fin du cours dire bah
j'ai pas compris le court c'est plus dur
alors qu'avec nous il peut venir on peut
très bien prendre 25 élèves dans la
durant la semaine il éparpille le temps
pour apprendre et pour écouter dans ce
collège de 700 élèves implantée au coeur
d'une cité sensible les aides éducateurs
de par leur âge ont un contact différent
avec les élèves
on a un peu les confidents une qui vient
nous raconter un petit peu ce qui leur
arrive dans leur famille dans le
quartier et je crois que le fait de
venir au collège et pouvoir en même
temps parle à quelqu'un mais je crois
que c'est important ça leur apporte
beaucoup
ils prennent du temps avec nous et
devant le géant de l'acier et quand le
temps de nous expliquer comme aldi la
plus d'importance
voilà ça brezellec et nous prennent à
notre niveau
s'ils veulent pas du tout c'est à faire
ce qu'on sait pas faire cet élève
turbulent vient d'être expulsé de sa
classe est placé en études chez les
aides éducateurs line est rare que je te
dise est une erreur de parcours en est
qu'en début d'année
bon on repartirait d'accord les élèves
nés les emplois je ne qualifie jamais
d'emploi je ne les appelle jamais les
emplois jeunes les élèves disent les
médiateurs c'est quand même intéressant
que ce sont les élèves qui le plus
souvent les appels les médiateurs alors
est-ce que des élèves savent vraiment ce
qu'il ya ce que veut dire sans ce
médiateur bien soudés car il les appelle
comme ça
la présence de ces médiateurs a permis
de désamorcer certains conflits même si
faute de formation et d'expérience
leur mission éducative a ses limites au
fil des mois ces jeunes chômeurs ont su
dessiner le profil d'un nouvel emploi
toul inverse d'un petit boulot à paris
fin de la grève des cheminots sur le
réseau saint-lazare l'arrêt de travail
avaient été décidés à la suite
d'agressions commises contre des agents
de la sncf
des mesures de sécurité supplémentaires
ont été décidées et puis reprise du
travail également des agents de conduite
sncf de la ligne c du rer et grévistes
estiment avoir obtenu des avancées
intéressantes quant à des recrutements
nouveau en cisjordanie dans la partie de
la ville d'hébron occupés par israël
deux bombes ont explosé alors qu'elles
étaient jetés contre un véhicule de
l'armée israélienne
vingt personnes ont été blessées dont
huit palestiniens
c'est aujourd'hui yom kippour en israël
le grand pardon et l'armée est en état
d' alerte sur tout le territoire
trois jours après sa victoire électorale
monsieur gerhard schröder bientôt
officiellement chancelier de la
république fédérale d'allemagne
successeur d'helmut kohl était en visite
aujourd'hui à paris il a été reçu par le
président de la république et par le
premier ministre il nous a accordé un
entretien que nous avons enregistré il y
à quelques minutes auparavant
voici la première journée à paris du
nouveau dirigeant allemand reportage
philippe rochot jean cornu patrick des
semis les premiers pas de jacques chirac
et gerhard schröder dans les jardins de
l'elysée les deux hommes ne se
connaissaient pas mais après le départ
des loups de colle c'est sur eux que
vont s'appuyer les rapports franco
allemand des rapports qui resteront
solides affirme le nouveau chancelier
après être revenu sur ses déclarations
où il souhaite élargir cet axe à la
grande bretagne
notamment en ce qui concerne la
conception de la relation franco
allemande et les exigences de la
construction européenne
nous nous sommes trouvés tout à fait sur
la même ligne ce dont je me réjouis
gerhard schröder estime même que jacques
chirac est un social démocrate modéré et
qu'il n'y a pas de grande différence
avec les jo ce point une impression
confirmée lors de sa visite au musée
rodin de meudon que le premier ministre
français a voulu présenter au futur
chancelier le poète allemand reiner
maria rilke a été secrétaire de rodin et
schroeder est un amateur d'art et de
poèmes fraudeur a voulu montrer qu'il
connaissait ses classiques en récitant
luton de riders maria rilke entretiens
politiques ensuite fraudeurs adhère à la
proposition française de renforcer les
institutions financières mondiales pour
que l'europe puisse affronter les crises
mais aussi que les européens puissent
lutter ensemble contre le chômage
mais l'état des relations franco
allemandes ou le problème de la
contribution allemande au financement de
l'union européenne ne représente pas le
seul souci pour gerhard schröder qui
doit commencer dès demain des
négociations avec les verts pour la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
monsieur gerhard schröder bonsoir à vos
côtés d' entre correspondants permanents
berlin olivier werner vous êtes à
l'ambassade d'allemagne à paris je
rappelle aux téléspectateurs vous avez
dirigé le land de basse-saxe depuis 1990
et que vous venez d'être élu 7e
chancelier de la république d'allemagne
mais comment vous qualifiez
politiquement faites-vous partie de
l'europe socialiste êtes vous un social
démocrate comme tony blair et lionel
jospin ou bien un centriste car vous
avez en effet parler de nouveau centre
je suis social démocrate et il ya des
raisons pour cela
mais le nouveau centre qu'il s'agit de
conquérir ce n'est pas une contradiction
au plan politique par rapport au fait
que je suis social démocrate c'est la
conséquence logique la social-démocratie
revendique le centre politique c'est ce
que nous avons fait en allemagne
monsieur chanteur votre passé est
intéressant vous êtes un ancien marxiste
vous n'avez jamais caché un ancien
gauchiste également gauchistes pur et
dur
on vous dit aujourd'hui très proche des
patrons dit même de vous que vous êtes
le camarade des patrons et vos
détracteurs vous qualifie aussi de
girouette alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez tout ça j'en pense c'est très
simple ceux qui n'apprennent pas au
cours de leur vie ne peuvent pas moi je
ne rejette rien de mon passé j'ai bien
c'est ce que j'ai fait je les fais
volontiers chez lutter pour la justice
sociale et je crois que c'est le seul
moyen de réaliser la citrouille j'ai
appris young pas pareil je les fais
volontiers vous avez eu à paris une
journée très chargée vous aurez demain à
bonn une journée très compliqué vous
allez commencer les négociations avec
les verts les verts sont très exigeants
ils demandent une augmentation du prix
de l'essence l'abandon du tout nucléaire
comment ça va se passer et combien de
portefeuilles ministériels vous allez
leur confier je ne vais pas le dire à la
télévision française pas plus qu'à la
télévision allemande ça fera l'objet des
négociations de coalition
il faut évaluer la pondération plus de
40% des électeurs se sont engagés pour
les sociaux-démocrates plus de 6% pour
les verts c'est une opération que l'on
va reprendre évidemment le programme de
coalition
ça va être tout à fait déterminant nous
allons miser sur la lutte contre le
chômage
nous allons miser sur la résorption de
la du déficit de formation pour les
jeunes démocrates c'est la stabilité
économique n'est pas d'expérimentations
tout à fait hasardeuse c'est la
stabilité on peut s'y fier en france
monsieur gerhard schröder l'allemagne va
assumer la présidence européenne partir
du 1er janvier
alors est-ce que vous allez privilégier
comme ce fut historiquement le cas un
axe paris berlin berlin paris ou est-ce
que étant un peu plus anglophile
peut-être par tradition vous même est ce
que vous entendez privilégier un trio
c'est-à-dire berlin londres et paris
hazeaux eh bien je ne veux pas d'un
ménage à trois
ça sous-entend du tout à fait quelque
chose de différent
les relations franco-allemandes des
femmes dynamiques
on peut y ajouter quelque chose à
renforcer notre coopération il faut que
les deux pays soient tout à fait ouvert
à toi je pense de la grande bretagne au
processus euromed les relations
franco-allemandes sont un élément
déterminant mais ce n'est pas une
exclusivité
et ce n'est d'ailleurs pas m'exciter que
revendiquent les relations franco
allemandes pour les français comme pour
les allemands en europe
il est essentiel d'avoir également une
très bonne relation avec les
britanniques et de même que la grande
bretagne il est essentiel d'avoir une
bonne relation avec le reste de l'europe
monsieur se redresse qu'il est difficile
pour un chancelier allemand de
travailler avec un gouvernement français
de gauche c'est un président de la
république qui ne l'est pas est ce que
cette cohabitation vous dérange mais
n'ont qu'à me dérange absolument pas
qu'on appelle la corée tentation
évidemment je ne connais déjà un petit
peu et son sentiment après les
discussions que j'ai menée aujourd'hui
c'est que sera dans les points
essentiels la france parle d'une seule
voix
je remercie monsieur schoder ci détecte
ce cet entretien était enregistrée vers
19h15 réunion d'urgence du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu sur le kosovo demain
cette réunion intervient au lendemain de
nouveaux massacres commis par l'armée
serbe dans le centre du kosovo
commentaires patrice romedenne
du massacre seul un enfant de deux mois
réchapper sa mère lui a servi de
bouclier
ce groupe d'une vingtaine d'albanais
fuyaient les combats quand il est tombé
nez à nez avec des hommes portant
l'uniforme de l'armée serbe selon le
témoignage des habitants du coin
tous ont été torturées avant d'être
achevé autre scénario même épilogue à 30
km de là la carriole d'une famille
albanaise tombe dans un ravin elles
attendent l'aide ce sont des soldats qui
arrive hommes femmes enfants pas de
survivant là encore les villageois
accusent les serbes et leurs témoignages
se devine sur des visages se figent la
détresse et l'incrédulité belgrade
dément toute participation à ces tueries
pendant ce temps la campagne du kosovo
fument toujours trahissant la
persistance de combat auquel l'armée
serbe se dit étrangère
d'ailleurs ces soldats s'en vont comme
habité par une forme de sérénité
et puis cinq membres de l'armée
yougoslave ont été tuées dans l'ouest du
kosovo par des tirs en provenance du
territoire de l'albanie vient
d'apprendre en algérie une nouvelle
opération menée par les forces de
sécurité contre un groupe armé islamiste
près de saïda 17 personnes ont été tuées
la télévision algérienne a longuement
montrer les cadavres des islamistes au
sénat la bataille est engagée pour
l'élection à la présidence de cette
assemblée entre l'udf sortant monsieur
rené monory et le rpr messieurs
christian poncelet les intentions de
vote restent relativement indécise et
cela ne crée pas un bon climat au sein
de la majorité sénatoriale de droite
reportage jean baptiste prévalu bernard
koné au sénat les réveils sont parfois
brut ou un président à élire par exemple
et voilà le palais du luxembourg en émoi
conciliabules supputations aparté
derrière les dorures
les grandes manoeuvres ont commencé
l'enjeu ce fauteuil
à 75 ans le centriste rené monory
pensait sollicité tranquillement un
troisième mandat mais tapie derrière son
bureau de la commission des finances le
rpr christian poncelet 70 ans tout juste
rêve de lui ravir sa place et chacun
sort ses atouts rené monory souligner
son rôle dans l'opposition
son expérience ses bonnes relations avec
jacques chirac
de son côté christian poncelet vente son
propre dynamisme son projet pour le
sénat de demain ses bonnes relations
avec la chirac
à chacun sa candidature ses soutiens à
chacun ses arguments longuement
soigneusement pesé jusqu'à présent et
quand même après puis kerpert
l'assemblée nationale lorsqu'elle est
majorité allait plus ses repères que
l'udf dont que le sénat qui est un peu
plus ceux du df pierre péan fois sur
cette ruse en support ces passionnés
vous savez ma candidature n'est pas le
fruit d'un caprice n'est pas non plus le
résultat d'une cession l'obstination ni
la conséquence d'une querelle de
personnes je dirais même que ma
candidature dépasse un peu minable
personnes en principe christian poncelet
ne peut compter que sur le groupe rpr
qui pèse moins que tout l'udf et les
libéraux réunis
mais au sénat rien n'est jamais sûr ni
les sourires ni les poignées de main
le scrutin s'annonce serré un troisième
homme pourrait même surgir entre deux
tours la seule certitude pourtant c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas vraiment de sens
barre de man le sénat s'agite un peu
tous les trois ans et il reste à droite
près de nice dans un bateau amarré à
saint-laurent-du-var les deux tableaux
impressionnistes de monnaie et sisley
volés au musée des beaux-arts de nice la
semaine dernière ont été retrouvés deux
hommes ont été interpellés dont l'un
serait un ami du conservateur du musée
le conservateur à l'issue d'une garde à
vue est en effet passé aux aveux
voilà nous allons maintenant rejoindre
benoît duquesne au salon de l'automobile
non loin du siège de france télévisions
c'est le 100e mondial de l'automobile il
me semble me dois que vous êtes parmi
les vieilles dames et bien que vous nous
trouvez dans le hall 8 c'est ici que
sont exposées toutes les voitures qui
ont marqué l'histoire de l'automobile
comme cette importance est fort de thé
pourquoi cette foire de thé et bien
parce que ça a été la première voiture
conçue fabriquée à la chaîne il y a eu
15 millions d'exemplaires de cette
voiture ce qui était ahurissant pour
l'époque et ça l'est toujours d'ailleurs
j'ai regardé cette autre voiture par
exemple c'est une renault une renault de
1924 on croit souvent que renault a
commencé à fabriquer des toutes petites
voitures c'est vrai qu'il l'a fait me
l'a fait aussi des voitures qui étaient
tout à fait concurrentiel des grandes
marques de l'époque
alors regardez par exemple cette voisins
c'est le voisin et bien elle est restée
célèbre parce qu'elle a un design assez
incroyable cette traction
c'est plus la peine de la présente est
l'attraction sait à quel point nous a
marqués la peugeot 402 éclipse qui était
aussi remarquer par son design est aussi
par ses innovations technologiques
et puis la bugatti royale bien sûr la
bugatti royale il y en a eu en tout et
pour tout six dans le monde et celle que
vous voyez maintenant été celle de
monsieur bugatti alors en 1898 le salon
avait lieu pour la première fois dans
les salles ou dans l'est dans les
jardins des tuileries ensuite ça a été
au grand palais et chaque fois et bien
les présidents de l'époque les inaugurer
ces salons en grande pompe sa voix ça
c'est toujours le cas d'ailleurs puisque
demain ça sera monsieur chirac qui sera
ici les vocations avec patrice rondelle
raymond poincaré au grand palais en 1919
monsieur le président salue alors
l'effort de l'industrie après 52 mois de
guerre
à la vérité on pourrait apprendre
l'histoire de france et ses présidents
en se penchant sur celle du salon de
l'auto vous apercevez vincent auriol en
47 voici son successeur en 54 rené coty
a inauguré son premier salon de l'auto
et ce n'est pas une petite à plein
les présidents tenez voilà pompidou ont
toujours honoré de leur présence cette
manifestation qui célèbre le culte de la
voiture
cet objet qui fait rêver les hommes et
marcher le commerce
et de gold crown at il fait pour la
réputation de la ds de citroën dont on
nous vante les qualités des laughton
1955 des courbes et du kof
m
et un et deux et trois la bs c'était le
confort l'espace la dauphine c'était la
suspension inusable acquis cette année
une nouvelle suspension baptisé aéro
stable qui donne à en juger d'excellents
résultats
la deux chevaux c'était rigolo 7 4
chevaux c'était renault et on pouvait
toujours rêver
jaguar anglaise la voiture la plus
rapide du monde avec son volant réglable
a suscité nombre de curiosités la
présence de la mercedes claironnait la
rentrée de l'industrie allemande dans le
circuit mondial
ça c'était dans 51 et en 58 pour
concurrencer les belles étrangères think
avait imaginé la beaulieu équipés d'un
téléviseur d'un magnétophone à cassette
encastrable et d'un téléphone par lequel
la secrétaire se faisait dicter le
courrier du jour et du patron
installé à l'arrière
en 62 le salon qui traîne au grand
palais pour la porte de versailles
on y célèbre reine avènement du turbo en
78 la mue de la dèche et rappelez vous
messieurs
cette fameuse martial a très vite je
crois pour l'attenté mais qui nous
obsède toujours pour demande pour
annoncer pas non plus mais en tout cas
depuis 1960 le salon se tient non plus
dans le coeur de paris mais ici porte de
versailles pour des questions de place
mais aussi d'embouteillages alors nous
sommes ici à côté de concept car qu'est
ce que c'est que des concepts cars et
bien c'est en quelque sorte l'idée que
se font les constructeurs de ce que
pourra être la voiture dans un an deux
ans trois ans mais ça ne veut pas dire
que ce sont des mots ce sont des
voitures que vous allez voir dans les
rues de paris ou d'ailleurs
ça n'est pas toujours le cas mais ça
peut le devenir regardez par exemple
cette voiture si elle vous dit sans
doute quelque chose eh bien cette
voiture c'est tout simplement le concept
car qui a précédé la mégane scénic alors
des concepts car il en est bien sûr sur
le salon aujourd'hui regardez par
exemple cette très belle chrysler avec
eux ses formes extraordinaires
elle montre un petit peu ce que ce qui
est la voiture aujourd'hui dans ce salon
et les très diversifiée dans ses formes
dans ses modèles et elle et je dirais
presque plus gai que la voiture des
années crise alors comment passe-t-on du
concept car à la voiture que vous
pourrez acheter mais on va voir avec lui
ben aziz un et daniel levy que c'est
beaucoup moins drôle si je puis dire
puisque ça commence tout simplement par
un cahier des charges avant même le
premier coup de crayon une voiture
commence à exister dans ce genre de
document ici le programme p1 appellation
secrète de la 206 peugeot là le projet
65 nom de code de celle qui deviendra
quatre ans plus tard la nouvelle clio la
signature du président sur le cahier des
charges donne le feu vert
voilà ici créer son style peugeot et
c'était ici effectivement dans lequel le
styliste a fait sa traduction avec le
crayon sur une boule de papier pour
trouver les premières idées sur le
dessin de 206 et voyez tout les signes
effet ce sont des signatures qui qui
force la dynamisme et cette impuissance
c'est ça les cas l échange au début
c'est vraiment le styliste qui fait sa
propre interprétation
après avoir étudié des centaines de
dessins le projet commence sa vie dans
l'ordinateur la sculpture général se
précisent le designer peut alors
passionné lui même les premières
maquettes
nous pénétrons ici dans les arènes
secrète où se cachent des dizaines de
maquettes et de prototypes en plâtre
grandeur nature probablement les renault
de demain retour chez peugeot cet homme
avait la responsabilité d'une enveloppe
de 6 milliards 300 millions de francs
pour transformer la maquette de 106 en
réalité c'est ici où tout se discute
jusqu'aux moindres détails comme par
exemple agrandir des phares mais là les
conséquences tombent en cascade évident
qu'il fallait reprend tout ce qui était
tout le riz au tour et même pour 2 mm
lui manquait 2 mm ça amène des un temps
énorme de retouche et de coûts puisque
les outillages d'emboutissage c'est une
chose très volumineuse et ça entraîne
des modifications importantes
sous les bureaux d'études une véritable
usine miniature s'activent à l'abri de
tous les regards
seul moyen de vérifier en situation la
faisabilité de l'imaginaire nous sommes
une zone maintenant de travail ou au
monde tout ce qui est véhicules de
pré-série dans les conditions réelles de
luz où tout est enfin validé vient le
jour de la naissance
la voiture est fabriqué les premières
206 sont stockés dans le parking de
l'usiné de sochaux trois mois avant la
commercialisation et à peine quatre ans
après la première ébauche alors rupture
au salon mais cette fois dans le hall
numéro un là où sont exposées toutes les
marques à commencer par peugeot et sa
206 la 206 fait sa première sortie
officielle ici au salon et la 206 est
bien c'est la voiture dans laquelle
monsieur peugeot un monsieur jean martin
folz vous fondez vos espoirs
presqu'autant que dans la 205 il a passé
des fonds non c'est vrai elle très
grands espoirs dans 206 cc déjà de très
grande réalité puisque nous avions de
lutte y sont ambitieux de cent mille
voitures à la fin de l'année et nous
sommes sûrs de le battre dès maintenant
et vous espérez faire cinq cent mille
voitures les prochaines c'est énorme
au moins 500 mille voitures et les
prochaines c'est à dire que plus que
maman je n'ai fait que 205 et c'est
quasiment un coup de poker pour vous si
ça marche par la 206 est grave ça marche
pas de sens si ce ne serait pas une
bonne nouvelle mais le susurre qu'elle
marchera très bien alors on est devant
autre chose à 7 ce qu'on appelle on en
parlait tout à l'heure des concepts car
celui ci s'appelle le ces trois là on
est chez citroën à l'autre l'autre
facette du groupe et ce concept car on
le présente un petit peu comme
l'éventuel futur de chevaux c'est ça
c'est presque cela veut dire est que
nous montrons ce soir à la fois deux
voitures une voiture de demain la xantia
picasso et puis une voiture d'après
demain ce que cette voiture c3 ses
voitures ses trois c'est un concept car
c'est une idée de ce que seront les
citroën de demain et dans trois ans ou
quatre ans nous sortirons une voiture
sont ce principe alors je vous propose
de faire quelque chose que vous n'êtes
peut-être pas l'habitude de faire c'est
de me suivre et
d'aller à la rencontre de quelqu'un qui
est je sais pas comment l'appeler votre
ennemi votre concurrent votre adversaire
c'est monsieur choisir c'est le patron
de renault qui nous attend ici est une
rencontre entre vous deux à la
télévision je crois que ça c'est bas
jamais fait donc voilà monsieur je
souhaite there alors comment il faut
vous appelez il faut vous appeler comme
des amis des ennemis des adversaires des
concurrents ce à quoi des concurrents
sûrement des ennemis sûrement pas des
amis et des concurrents les relations
entre peugeot et renault se sont assagis
et une époque n était pas très bons avec
monsieur calvet cette fois ci c'est fini
c'est des relations entre deux
concurrentes très proches qui ont
beaucoup en commun mais qui ont chacun a
envie de gagner nos compétitions
autrement dit zhu plan commercial tout
ne sais pas mais pour défendre la
voiture qui nous réunit alors vous
pousser à vous deux là 4 million de
voitures par an ah oui les normes
vous êtes le 9e et le neuvième et
dixième constructeur au monde d'après
les chiffres et gilles va avoir c'est
énorme
4 million de voitures par an c'est
énorme mais en même temps on se dit que
par rapport à des géants comme general
motors comme ford comme daimler qui
vient de fusionner avec chrysler ça peut
paraître petit alors quand vous voyez
toutes ces fusions qui ont lieu dans
l'automobile y compris volkswagen
récemment etc
comment est ce que vous voyez une
réaction possible ça serait quoi pour
vous le souhaitez pour moi c'est une
réponse simple c'est la croissance
rentable c'est à dire que mon objectif
c'est que renault dans douze ans soit à
quatre millions de véhicules par
lui-même en grandissant dans le monde
donc la réponse au géant c'est le
grandir et vous monsieur falls pour moi
j'veux bien sûr que le deal ou césaire
c'est de grandir
c'est aussi de trouver par d'autres
techniques que la fusion des entreprises
l'effet de taille et la productivité la
solution de psa ce sont les coopérations
avec d'autres constructeurs coopération
avec renault depuis presque trente ans
l'opération avec fiat
et puis nous l'avons annoncé hier une
coopération très importante avec ford
d'en développer ensemble une nouvelle
famille de moteurs
vous allez vous isolez faire un moteur
ensemble mais l'idée de fusionner à la
limite
peugeot psa et et renault non sens et
c'est une mauvaise idée c'est un de nos
points d'accord absolue parce que nous
perdrions je crois notre âme a essayé de
nous rapprocher entre nous on a
l'impression un petit peu que tout le
monde est euphorique dans ce salon
on a connu des salons un peu plus terne
et sa longue crise là on voit des
voitures qui sont belles qui sont
variées qui sont colorés c'est votre
impression aussi tout va bien pour vous
aujourd'hui où c'est une écoute et une
illusion franck dubois effectivement il
ya des voitures que nous présentons je
pense que les constructeurs français psa
et je crois renault vont bien montre
qu'effectivement l'automobile française
ne se porte pas si mal et je crois que
les voitures que nous montre aujourd'hui
sont la preuve de notre dynamisme
ça va bien aujourd'hui mais demain avec
l'arrivée des japonaises par exemple des
coréennes qui profite d'une monnaie qui
s'effondre est-ce que ça c'est pas
quelque chose que vous redoutez quand
vous voyez les xacti slatina gatti ce
qui va être par toyota
je suis allé voir la voiture japonaise
je suis revenu j'ai regardé les nôtres
et je suis assez confiant cela dit on
travaille je veux dire on ne les battra
pas sans travailler et on travaille on
travaillait plus inventifs que plus
originaux meilleur en qualité meilleure
en cours donc à être mire que parce que
c'est une bataille et c'est une bataille
qu'on veut gagner alors je vous propose
de voir des images qui sont des images
en fait d'eux des espaces parce que vous
avez été les premiers à appeler cette
voiture l'espace et c'est devenu presque
un nom générique et on va voir que sur
le salon cette année bon peugeot on sait
ça c'est la xsara picasso citroën où ils
ressentent très très fort à une autre
voiture de chez renault d'ailleurs très
différente au contraire est-ce que
monsieur je réserve j'ai pas
l'impression quand on voit tous ces
constructeurs uns sont venus à l'espace
bon d'abord d'avoir fait une superbe
affaire quand vous avez dit beaucoup
avec matra et aussi d'avoir été copié
par tout le monde et je crois que chaque
constructeur essaye d'innover d'inventer
des idées nous travaillons à être un
moteur d'idées depuis 100 ans et les
bonnes idées elle se diffuse ça fait
partie de la nature des choses et l'idée
demain ça serait quoi monsieur falls et
bien c'est par exemple la gratte nous
décevoir c'est la c3 que nous avons vu
tout à l'heure c'est aussi des progrès
de la technologie des progrès dans les
moteurs au feu à des voitures qui sont à
la fois plus sûr et meilleur cependant
l'environnement alors sur la technologie
puisqu'on en parle vous propose d'aller
rejoindre l'udc l'a 10 1 qui se trouve
pas très loin d'ici pas loin d'une une
voiture concurrente de chez mercedes la
classe s qui sort maintenant avec tout
un tas d'innovations technologiques luc
bizarre c'est à vous écouter pour
découvrir les innovations d'aujourd'hui
mais aussi
si celle que l'on pourra trouver demain
je vous propose d'embarquer à bord de la
nouvelle mercedes classe s la première
voiture à proposer à son client
un radar anticollision un détecteur
placé à l'avant de la voiture va repérer
comme une tour de contrôle ceux qui se
trouvent devant elle et en cas de
ralentissement ou de freinage la voiture
va d'elle-même adapter sa vitesse est ce
aussi longtemps que l'obstacle se
maintient devant
il suffit de régler cette molette pour
choisir sa distance de sécurité saas est
aujourd'hui mais encore plus fort
actuellement au texas la voiture est
directement prise en charge par des
capteurs noyé dans la chaussée et des
caméras embarquées dans ce cas le
conducteur n'aura plus obligatoirement
besoin de tenir son volant ni même
d'intervenir sur les pédales c'est un
peu comme dans un train chacun même
celui qui est derrière le volant se
laisse conduire les constructeurs font
également beaucoup d'efforts pour le
confort intérieur par exemple dans cette
voiture la climatisation va repérer à la
fois le nombre de passagers dans cette
voiture mais aussi la position du soleil
et en fonction de cela elle va donner à
chacun la température idéale
et puis vous le savez le multimédia fait
son apparition dans la majorité des
voitures aujourd'hui le guidage par
satellite par exemple en est à sa
deuxième génération beaucoup plus
intelligente puisque informé en temps
réel le système propose automatiquement
un itinéraire de rechange en cas
d'embouteillages c'est ce que l'on
appelle la voiture intelligente seul
problème ces systèmes se trouve à bord
de voitures chères celles ci par exemple
coûte l'équivalent de 10 wingo l'ordi
twingo ça fait beaucoup surtout que nous
sommes maintenant à nouveau sur le stand
renault est toujours avec vous monsieur
chouette their monsieur falls est resté
est retourné dans son stand peugeot ce
qui est normal ma foi et nous sommes
devant la vel satis qui est un concept
car votre concept car alors célèbre
voiture pleine de technologies
révolutionnaires évidemment c'est comme
ça que vous imaginez la limousine de
demain c'est comme ça que nous imaginons
le luxe à la française
au fond c'est un peu trop habitués à une
image traditionnelle du luxe nous nous
pensons que la france peut inventer une
nouvelle image du luxe d'esthétique
d'audace et cela représente notre idée
de ce que ça pourrait être caisse dans
une voiture en termes d'innovation qui
est ce qu'on pourrait retrouver dans les
voitures qui seront effectivement créé
par exemple un coupé à deux portes mais
où on accède aux places arrière comme
aux places avant sans difficulté des
portes qui s'ouvrent toutes seules un
toit qui couve à jusqu au pare brise des
roues plus grande
un monospace bicorps 20 bref toute une
série d'idées que vous retrouvez là
rassemblés en un véhicule et que vous
verrez sur une succession de véhicules
renault parce que nous sommes toujours
un moteur d'idées alors elle a des
formes assez étonnante en même temps
enfin futuriste si on peut parler comme
ça en même temps vous habituerez
l'entente se promène dans le salon c'est
marrant de voir que une voiture qui
réunit beaucoup de d'assentiment c'est
la new beetle c'est une en fait une
coccinelle amélioré qui nous arrive des
états unis qui sera je crois
commercialisé en 99 en france et tout le
monde veut la voir est ce que vous
pensez
beaucoup aux femmes quand vous créez les
voitures nous pensons beaucoup aux
femmes
oui là vous les voyez la twingo la clio
d'abord nous ne les voyons pas comme
uniforme
il ya toutes sortes de familles et les
femmes qui travaillent à des femmes qui
ne travaillent pas et elles veulent une
voiture qui soit à leur service elles
veulent pas être service de la voiture
et donc nous voulons une voiture qui
répondent à leurs désirs qui répondent à
leurs besoins qui soit amical
bon ce ne sont pas donc dès ce sont des
consommatrices en titre les flammes pour
vous ce ne sont pas seulement des femmes
noires de la voiture ou et sept rapports
l'idée que l'homme achète la voiture et
que la femme l'accompagnait est une idée
qui n'est plus vrai il y a les femmes
qui achètent des voitures des hommes qui
achètent des voitures des couples qui
achètent des voitures et on n'est pas
sexiste chez renault alors je vous
propose de voir comment la pub a souvent
était sexiste pour les femmes puisque la
femme a souvent servi de potiche faut
bien le dire pour revendre et pour
mettre en valeur encore plus les des
belles carrosseries
c'est un sujet de jean-jacques du foie
pour remonter jusqu'à l'époque où les
autos démarré à coups de manivelle et où
les femmes n'était que passagère
il nous a suffi de descendre dans les
entrailles de la maison de la pub
caverne d'ali baba remplie de films et
d'un faux à propos d'un faux il faudrait
se rappeler qu'au début du siècle
certains journalistes écrivez à cause de
leurs imperfections naturel les femmes
ne conduiront jamais il faut dire qu'en
ce temps-là les bagnoles étaient des
monstres et le cinoche encore muet
le sonores commencent dès 1927 et la
publicité adoptera le sonore dans les
années 30 un petit peu plus tard facile
et sympa et très vite la pub s'aperçoit
qu'une fille bien carrossées cet idéal
pour mettre en valeur les voitures de
grandes marques
là nous sommes dans l'entre-deux-guerres
ou le fin du fin c'est lé concours
d'élégance
désormais la belle à apprivoiser la bête
mais la bête s'est affinée et la belle a
évolué c'est pas très sexy à l'epo c'est
les publicités à l'époque sont
extrêmement prudents bourgeoise et on
pense plutôt à 10 des défilés de mode
quand les femmes arrivent chaque côté
avec des gants et des robes longues et
bien entendu tout ça est du meilleur
goût dans le meilleur des mondes
après la guerre changement de décor du
noir on passe à la couleur les courses
quotidiennes
quatre portes
la 4 e vo renault et la zone où voter
verts et la panne modernes consomment la
voiture est devenue un produit de masse
dans les années 50 c'est la famille et
effectivement les voitures sont
présentés différemment et sont
accessibles non montre le coffre pour
déjà on peut mettre plein de valises de
dans les enfants mais y en a au moins
trois c'est vraiment l'image de la
famille française qui s'embarquent dans
le tram bus l'ariège est là alors la
femme est plutôt positif pour nous un
peu la femme ménagère l'utilitaire et
c'est vrai un petit côté choisi la
voiture de la joie de vivre dont fine
passant de 2 après la pionnière
l'élégante et la consommatrice nous
arrivons aux années 90
et là ça devient très chaud la publicité
automobile érotise les filles à fond les
manettes et d'un modèle à l'autre on
culbute ou en car à l'aube de l'an 2000
les filles sont vraiment renversante et
ce ne sont pas les américains qui me
démentiront non c'est aspect utiliser
l'automobile il ya quand même beaucoup
de second degré voire de référence et
les valeurs subconsciente mais en tout
cas il faut quand même voir tous avec
distance et ils sont amusés moi ça
m'amuse beaucoup de choses quant à
l'avenir et bien il semble virtuel grace
jones et déjà ringarde maintenant les
élégantes qui sont des héroïnes de jeux
vidéo façon lara croft est monté alors
c'est quoi l'idée de lara croft jeune
lara croft c'est le croisement de james
bond et indiana jones mais en fait au
féminin une femme qui a du succès c'est
une femme qui est vainqueur les hommes
donc ça plaît aux dames
ça plaît aux hommes parce qu'elle a une
silhouette comme il faut elle a les
armes qu'il faut pour se battre dans la
vie puis d'abord et avant tout une voix
c'est quelqu'un qui est vainqueur
décidément on n'arrête pas le progrès
dix sept ans après l'invention d'airbag
les pings ne sont déjà vu en chair et en
os mais trêve de nostalgie une
conclusion s'impose en sentant la pas
mais l'auto ont fait un sacré boulot
voilà on arrive à la fin de cette page
spéciale au salon de l'automobile au
mondial de l'automobile
vous allez le voir il ya beaucoup de
monde déjà ici ce soir il faut dire ce
soir est un peu privée sur invitation
pour les constructeurs demain c'est
jacques chirac qui inaugure le salon
et puis il sera après ouvert au public
pour une dizaine de jours est libre à
vous de vous y rendre claude bonsoir
évidemment on essaiera d'éviter les
embouteillages merci benoît pour toute
cette page spéciale et je rappelle à
ceux d'entre vous qui sont intéressés
vous pouvez utiliser le site internet de
france 2 pour avoir tous les détails sur
ce 100e mondiale voilà l'adresse du site
internet de france 2 et puis dernier
l'information officielle que la
commission antidopage de la fédération
cycliste suisse décidé de suspendre pour
huit mois trois coureurs suisses de
l'équipe festina alex zülle laurent
dufaux et armin meier
et puis laurent jalabert renonce à
participer aux championnats du monde de
cyclisme début octobre aux pays bas ils
avaient été pré sélectionné dans
l'équipe de france compte tenu de son
état physique et psychologique
je rappelle à la fin de cette édition
deux informations que nous avons
développées comme ce journal a lyon la
justice enquête sur les conditions de la
mort de 10 personnes à l'hôpital edouard
herriot il s'agit de savoir s'il ya un
lien entre une panne d'électricité
et ces décès et puis la visite de
monsieur guérard chaudet récemment élu
par les allemands futur chancelier
officiel de la république et vers
l'allemagne si j'allais rencontrer
monsieur jacques chirac et monsieur
lionel jospin qui est également notre
invité dans cette édition
dans quelques instants la météo d'isabel
martinez est assez pluvieux instable à
l'ouest plus calme à l'est à 20h50 un
téléfilm passage sous silence suivie de
ça se discute avec jean luc delarue se
discute s'intéressera aux troubles
sexuels à 0 heures 25 le dernier journal
avec florence du bras et puis le cercle
présenté par fils le fait qu'ils comme
une fois par mois accueillera tous les
critiques culturels
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités france
de lasbordes recevra pierre salignon de
responsable de médecins sans frontières
à propos de ce qui se passe en corée du
nord
à 13h carole gaessler rachid arhab à
demain 20h bonsoir merci
je
non